à
sexy baye sami naceri commence à ses
pairs bien moi je l'appelle le beurre
rouge et bleu mais tu aimes pas vous
aimez pas qu'on vous appelle beurre on
préfère maghrébins je crois bref elle
berce et sur les partis le matin et il
est gelé peur aux yeux bleus bon alors
ça roule ah ouais c'est le cas de le
dire
ouais ça roule on va parler d'europe si
le taxi 2 qui est bien parti pour faire
10 millions d'entrées on est à quatre
millions avec ça sera plus que 10 heures
on est à quatre millions on a fait la
moitié un peu plus de la moitié de la
vie de taxi un sur dix chez pas un nom
d'exploitation il était assez ce mignon
et on est à 4 millions en une semaine
c'est incroyable j'ai vu là j'ai pas
encore vu le 2 mai juillet s'est jamais
été bien à rire mais c'était bien
regardez donc j'avais battu les
visiteurs wars danger pokémon là il a
quoi de plus que le premier et deuxième
rangs il va plus vite
ah ça va encore plus vite ouais il va
plus vite
besson a fait en sorte d'étau fait tous
les personnages à vous avez moins
conduit à cotisations instants suivants
nom ouais on ne pouvait pas je n'ai pas
pu me faire plaisir comme je me suis
fait plaisir sur le ventre ouais parce
que s'il nous est arrivé un malheur la
chute il aurait été dommage quand on
voit la semaine finie taxi 3 c'est déjà
écrit dans la tête de l'udc ouais ouais
ouais ouais c'est écrit ouais c'est
tranquille là c'est un bon boulot
maintenant je crois que ça roule quoi
faut pas tomber dans le ridicule et puis
les sharks que besson c'est un mec
intelligent pour taxi les
extraterrestres mais bon les gendarmes y
en a bien eu 4 je veux dire je crois
qu'on peut se permettre d'aller jusqu'au
4 comme l'armé fatale et pourquoi pas
une cinquième s'il cats le public est au
rendez vous on se permettra de faire un
cinquième alors jusqu'à jusqu'à daniel
si vous aviez tout le temps des rôles de
maghrébins comme vous vite c'est à dire
que finalement c'est la première fois
même en france je crois que c'est la
première fois que il ya un acteur qui
s'appelle daniel et qui joue pas parce
que dans rise vous et votre bande le
film de thomas gilou 94
vous vous jouiez des gens de la banlieue
quoi mais là pour la première c'est la
première fois que ouais je crois qu'il y
en a quand même un petit peu il ya hier
jeudi il ya sami bouadjila il s'agit de
taghmaoui qui a réussi à peu à
travailler aux états unis
je crois qu'on est et puis c'est pas une
demande
je crois qu'on est on est on est quatre
cinq six la dent dans le milieu du
cinéma ou
où les gens nous commence à nous donner
rochdi depuis un bon bout à bien la
banlieue mais nous on commence aussi à
se faire notre petite place si on nous
donne des rôles comme ça de français ou
alors si c'est des rôles de deux
maghrébins des jolis rôles
ouais proches disent et roschdy zem un
produit dont ils pensent que salman
rushdie aura jamais mais avant il y
avait avant il y avait au marché arif
mouloudji quoi way en france c'est que
les tarifs et mouloudji
on a parlé excusez moi mais ce soir on a
quand même parlé de liquide dans sa
génération
d'ormesson pierre de richie qui jouait
dans fiacre ah ouais bon alors le
deuxième place et le premier film taxi
bon c'est un triomphe absolu
le deuxième film c'est un film qui sort
le 12 avril est un film d'alexandre
arcady qui s'appelle la barre mon pays
tirée du roman de rené bonnell qui est
un bouquin excellent voilà que zoom zoom
mon garçon je montre à la caméra zoome
je te dis voilà alors avec antoine de
caunes mathilda may qui d'autre noah
quadra alors l'histoire de cette
histoire de d'antoine de caunes au
départ qui est une star de la télé qui
présente le journal télévisé
un jour il rencontre un vieil algérien
devant la chaîne de télé oui boss et ce
vieil algérien lui montre une cassette
où il ya une jeune fille qui enlève son
voile devant la caméra et on lui demande
d'aller la chercher parce que évidemment
on est très en danger ça se passe en 94
donc à l'époque et mais le génial fils
etc et donc il part en algérie pour
faire sortir pour faire sortir cette
fille et il s'aperçoit que c'est la
fille d'une fille qu'il avait abandonné
en 62 et là on découvre que lui et
pieds-noirs en fait il avait
complètement remis et tous sont passés
pieds-noirs et hatchback entre bath et
un entrelacement entre 62 et 94
alors voilà ben écoutez le plus simple
c'est qu'on regarde un ce qu'on garde un
extrait magnéto